es gibt ja einige maßnahmen die nicht
allen einleuchten zb warum dürfen
friseure öffnen und tattoo studios nicht
darüber wollen wir jetzt unter anderem
sprechen mit sophia thomalla die uns
zugeschaltet ist aus istanbul guten
morgen
demong friseure dürfen ab dem vierten
mai wieder öffnen aber piercing studios
nicht was halten sie davon
ja nichts also erst einmal begrüße ich
das auf jeden fall dass eine besserung
stattfindet dass die friseure definitiv
öffnen können es nicht schön ich glaube
ich einer der ersten wieder rennt
allerdings stimmen die
verhältnismäßigkeiten nicht dass wenn
man ein betracht zieht dass ein
tätowierer ein psa vielleicht eins bis
zwei kunden maximalen tag hatte denn so
eine tattoo sitzung ist mindestens 45
stunden unter den besten hygienischen
voraussetzungen stimmt die
verhältnismäßigkeit nicht denn eins bis
zwei kunden reicht einem tattoo oder
einem tätowierer einen tip-in nur einen
piercer um den laden aufrecht zu
erhalten und ich bitte schön finden wenn
man da vielleicht noch eine lösung
finden könnte wie sollte die aussehen
ihrer meinung nach sie haben ja den
gesundheitsministerien sparen
ziemlich direkt angegangen über
instagram direkt angegangen habe ich
nicht sondern ich habe einfach für die
szene und natürlich auch im eigenen
interesse einfach nur gefragt sondern
ich würde dich schön finden dass wenn
man wenn die wenn die frisur wieder
öffnen dürften dass sie dir zu lesen
auch wieder essen dürften das wäre mein
vorschlag über mein anliegen
sie haben ja viele tattoos und können
das vergleichen wie sind denn die
hygienestandards wenn sie vergleichen
dass die tattoo studios die sie kennen
und die friseure also erst einmal muss
man ja immer damit rechnen dass jemand
vielleicht in welche viren in sich trägt
die man jetzt persönlich nicht noch
übertragen bekommen möchte das heißt
tätowierer müssen immer stündlich
desinfizieren müssen immer handschuhe
tragen und wenn es jetzt daran liegen
sollte das vielleicht ein titel wäre
noch ein mundschutz tragen sollte
da kann man sich auch darauf einigen
aber die hygienestandards in einem
tattoo oder piercing studio sind
wirklich gegeben und da eigentlich abend
also nicht verbieten zu können noch
weiterhin geschlossen zu bleiben und
ersparen
sagte er auch dass der drang nach einem
nach einer neuen frisur mehr gegeben ist
noch mal als nach einem neuen tattoo
kann ich verstehen aber es gibt ja auch
gewisse leser zentren sind die nur
darauf spezialisiert sind tattoos und
fern und die haben ja auch offen also es
ist also dran da sich einst entfernt
sehen lassen aber kein zu bekommen da
stimmen die verhältnisse ja auch nicht
das hat der gesunde mann dass er ihnen
persönlich geantwortet er sagte auch der
wunsch nach einem haarschnitt ist
aktuell größer als der nach einem
piercing dafür haben sie also kein
verständnis durch den punkt verstehe ich
schon aber mir ging es jetzt persönlich
ja auch nicht darum dass ich jetzt
morgen in ankara auf dem oberarm haben
möchte wo ich nicht warten kann sondern
es geht ja darum dass leute auch ihren
arbeitsplatz behalten und ich persönlich
trage natürlich auch so eigenen
interesse denn wenn in einer der
renommiertesten tätowiererin kein tattoo
studio hat bedeutet dass die leute sich
dann auf der wohnzimmercouch 1 verpassen
bekommen und dann kann man sich
natürlich auch gewisse dinge einfach wie
hepatitis et cetera
also das wäre sozusagen im interesse der
allgemeinheit gehen dass die studios
wieder öffnen
damals so zusammenfassen naja politik
als noch haben wenn sie keiner haben
dann natürlich sie sind ja in istanbul
zur zeit bei ihrem freund loris karius
und istanbul es ja eine wahnsinnig große
lebhafte metropole
jetzt gibt es dort sehr strenge
ausgangssperren wie ist das für sie die
stadt so zu erleben also sehr strenge
ausgangssperren ist eigentlich überhaupt
nicht der fall sondern wir haben ja eine
ausgangssperre nur am wochenende
weil das wetter schön ist und die leute
wenn sie nicht arbeiten mehr auf den
straßen rumhängen wurde hier nach
ausgangssperre das wochenende verlangt
okay also das heißt wir dürfen
eigentlich über die woche rausgehen ganz
normal machen wir aber nicht wir sind
jetzt seit ungefähr sechs wochen in
quarantäne tatsächlich und wie ist das
so am wochenende wenn er die ganze stadt
komplett leer ist wie wir gerade auf den
bildern gesehen haben
ehrlich gesagt weiß ich das nicht weil
ich auch dann nicht rausgehen darf also
ich habe tatsächlich auch noch nicht
wirklich leid gesehen wie es ist in der
türkei wenn er keinen menschen auf der
straße ist denn wir sind ja selber nicht
draußen und unter der woche ist da gibt
es ja keinen
größeren unterschied die leute fahren
also leute über 65 dürfen nicht auf die
straße dürfen nicht raus und leute unter
20 nicht alle anderen dürfen erst mal
ganz normal weiter aus herzlichen dank
so vierte mal dass ich heute früh
zugeschaltet haben alles gehört